mana ants cards home looks a bit like an
antique store he can't sell everything
he salvages from the rivers straight
away it's best to collect as much as
possible before looking for a buyer in
recent weeks he's collected amulets
coins and glass beads mana comes home
with the whole pretty much every single
day but it doesn't always include
anything of real value so badly Michael
if I find something underwater that I
think could be gold I bite on it
most metals have a bitter taste but gold
doesn't taste of anything it's heavy and
smooth a gold breastplate is the most
valuable thing I ever found it was seven
years ago after the 2011 floods I got
1,300 euros for it I sold this ring for
800 euros that was a while ago
the buyers are antique dealers mana
doesn't want to name them he knows the
whole trade in sunken treasure is
illegal gray areas Michael do you are of
course all these things belong to
someone before they ended up in the
water
but as long as they aren't national
relics you can keep them I have had some
encounters with the authorities but one
man's trash is another man's treasure
mana lives in a house on stilts directly
on the river the settlement is called
Metacom and was built around a hundred
years ago
Manas grandfather was one of the first
inhabitants today the floating village
of Metacom is home to about a hundred
and twenty people most of the men are
treasure divers like mana mana
eleven-year-old daughter goes to school
and his wife Huey works as a chambermaid
in a hotel she used to go out with him
when he went diving but only as a
lookout traditionally women don't dive
themselves my Mina it's not women's work
unless you're especially brave the
thought of being underwater scares me
you don't know what's down there
shards of glass nails spider my husband
is an experienced diver but I still
worry every time he goes diving he could
have won and then that when when God
made back
mono learn to die from his father it's
the only skill he has his homemade
diving helmet is the most important
piece of equipment it weighs over 20
kilos
while Pryor lays anchor mother gets
ready for his first dive
that involves the traditional Wai Kru
ceremony mana pays his respects to his
ancestors and asks them to protect him
his partner puts the heavy helmet on his
head
and then he's off the waist of it pushes
him straight under there's zero
visibility underwater mana finally comes
back up
he shows us a handful of coins that he's
found
manners also brought up some sludge from
the riverbed which they'll sift through
in search of other valuables
today's findings include a piece of
fishing sinker and a few more coins from
the 19th century I'm happy enough coins
like these aren't all that special I
find quite a few of them you can get one
or two hundred baht for them obviously
gold is much more valuable but gold
isn't something you find every day mana
and prior spent about six hours on the
water today taking it in turns to go
diving by the end of the day they've
recovered some two dozen old coins
they'll make about 25 euros over three
times more than what they would have
earned any minimum-wage job mana hopes
he'll be able to continue making a
living as a treasure diver the river is
a gift that keeps on giving